oh my god he will not let it go  you could tell he's latin because land  people are tenacious  my name is nick barilla and i'm  traveling the country to sit down with  some of the biggest latinx artists in  places that are meaning to them and help  tell their story hello hello how you  doing this particular building is the  chicano studies it's a pretty special  place for me we'll talk about their  journeys and careers and explore issues  of identity culture discrimination and  representation  i got scars in my head from hitting that  glass ceiling  trying to understand your culture and  your heritage and the roots that make  you the human being that you are sharing  it so that others can understand it  makes everybody stronger  this is scene  you